[Music]
yeah Millie's she's doing better she's
gonna get better really soon but she
unfortunately she hurt her knee I think
she slipped like it wasn't on set but
she slipped and fractured from me but
she's getting better
stranger things star Millie Bobbie Brown
had to skip the MTV movie and TV Awards
on Saturday night after breaking her
kneecap I have split my kneecaps I mean
she's in high spirits she's got a she's
got a bum knee should split her kneecap
and a half it's a gnarly picture but um
yeah no ID not on me but we'll see it
with Millie post in the next few days
but all I know is that she sent us she's
in a full leg Cassie yeah signing it
we're not signing it yeah I haven't seen
her since it's got a giant black cast
but we'll see what happens
she's getting better I hope she's okay
and I think I don't know I think she's
getting better soon you guys been
sending her some get well goody
yeah we've sent her a lot of videos and
cards and stuff her co-stars wished her
well from the red carpet and gave some
teases about what's to come in season
three new characters it's really fun
it's a it's set in the summer it's
really fun the season
yeah well I can't say too much but I
mean it's a great season so far it's set
in 85 there's 8 episodes and it's and it
does well if mixing both 1 & 2